some of the most confusing and
mysterious questions that we have about
Avengers and game come from time travel
and Captain America going back in time
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we all love that Captain America finally
got his last dance with Peggy Carter and
a happy ending at the end of Avengers in
game but having said that a lot of us
still have some questions about what
exactly happened when he went back in
time what year did he go back in time
were there two Captain America's in his
timeline which timeline was he living in
and how old was he when he returned at
the end of Avengers endgame now some of
these questions have been answered
before by the writers Christopher Markus
and Stephen McFeely and the directors of
course the Russo brothers but now a few
more of these questions about Captain
America going back in time have been
answered by none other than the visual
effects team for Avengers endgame I'll
break it all down in this video and just
a heads up I'll be announcing the winner
of the 500,000 subscriber giveaway
tomorrow on Saturday I'm also still
giving away an nintendo Swit so be sure
to subscribe and check on the link below
so you can enter the giveaway so in a
recent video with wired of the visual
effects team for Avengers in game
revealed how old Captain America was at
the end of Avengers end game so in the
case of Captain America what would a
Super Soldier look like if he had aged
106 years but when his skin looked like
so we did some development with that so
as you heard in the video the visual
effects team asked the question what
would Captain America looked like if he
was 106 years old so therefore he is 106
years old at the end of a vendor's
endgame no surprise there he has the
Super Soldier Serum inside of him so he
can live for a very long time of course
he has aged but the Super Soldier Serum
has kept him alive so that answers the
question of how old was he at the end of
Avengers in-game but we still have the
question of what year did he return to
Peggy Carter in the past well thanks to
a Good Samaritan on a reddit reddit
earth thanks reddit for memes we know
because this R editor did the math based
on Steve's age in Avengers in game of
106 years old he returned to Peggy
Carter in 1947 just a couple of years
after the war had ended as we know from
Captain America Civil War Peggy Carter
died in 2016 which means that her
Steve got to live together for 69 years
and that also means that Captain America
was 37 years old when he took the
Infinity stones back to their points in
time at the end of Avengers in game so
after everything that Captain America
has been through he still got to spend
69 years with the love of his life after
the events of Avengers endgame he was
finally able to get his last dance and
retire so let me know what you think
about this are you glad Captain America
finally got to settle down or would you
prefer that he would still be in the
Avengers and again don't forget to
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your favorite
superhero or villain so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 the winner will be chosen at
500,000 subscribers also check the link
in my description for a chance to win a
Nintendo switch and as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof